you sent out a tweet recently you said
that you got a compliment from a guy but
it came across as a little creepy and
I'm just wondering what did he say
what's that what's a creepy compliment
that you might get from a guy well I put
these free tips on Twitter and this one
was advising men to maybe not
start um if you're gonna compliment a
woman with her calves he would he do he
came up to you and said I like your
calves and said yes you have very
appealing calves yeah which is pretty
creepy because either you're lying and
doing it terribly and you're weird right
or you have a calf fetish yeah yeah well
I think it's maybe not a good idea to be
too specific you know what I mean yeah
got a perfect I mean a certain part like
to say like oh I really admire your
calves or your tear duct intrigues me
you know you feel like you want to push
back a little bit well just a bizarre
thing because if you meet someone for
the first time usually you're looking
here maybe understand a beloved you know
a little a little I get it but it's
strange if someone's like nice to meet
you your elbows are fascinating you're
like you're a creep well you are as an
attractive single woman you must have
guys coming up to you all the time what
do you do if you don't want to engage
with them or if they say something and
you kind of want it to end but you seem
like a nice person you don't want to be
mean I pretend that I don't speak
English mainly yes because I found if I
just politely declined like you know I'm
fine I didn't need a drink I would be
then at the mercy of the flip I call it
the flip the flip so you say would you
like to have a drink have a drink with
me
I'm no I'm fine thanks and then you end
up going well you know I didn't want to
buy you a drink anyway can you're not
even that cute okay get over yourself
bye okay they're like not how I talk
that's what I would say
and I'd be like I didn't want a drink
anyway that's me when I'm mad right
but wow people are like that they do
that a lot you get yelled at so it's
it's probably better then that's not
right first of all it's your prerogative
to say no I don't would rather not have
a drink yes it is my prerogative but
that doesn't seem to matter right so I
just pretend that I don't speak English
okay so I come up to and I say oh I'd
like to buy you a drink
my no my husband my husband that's
always a good one
yes my husband the professional wrestler
yeah he's coming yeah the best interview
trouble though to like struggle to
really understand that's the best part
of it that when you're you act like
you're interested but you just don't
speak English yes no I again right right
have you tried tinder no no I have not
tried tender I think the whole concept
of that app is broken
so sorry the people who build that
happen to making a lot of money off of
it but I'm sure I'm not gonna hurt you I
think the whole concept is broken I
think that men 9 out of 10 men you go on
there are looking to hook up fine but
not hook up you mean they want to have
sex that night
correct yes I'm just trying to cut to
the chase yes yeah that's what the men
want yeah they want a shebang bang and
nine out of ten with a bang bang bang
bang what a wonderful term from 1920
they're over there by the Packer doing
the old shebang bang
and I think 9 out of 10 women you know
they want to find the man that they're
gonna marry and will meet the parents
and they're gonna wait to their wedding
night like the whole idea is broken that
you're looking for the one intent on
either side right ok so I think we
should just swipe left on tinder
you